this is garrett a sandhill crane  if it wasn't for the maryland zoo in  baltimore he probably wouldn't be here  today  garrett was found wandering around a  home depot parking lot before being  rescued by the zoo  scattered throughout western and central  north america it is incredibly rare to  see them as far east as maryland  in the winter they migrate south  all the way down to northern mexico  tall grey and slender sand hill cranes  have long legs and necks  their large wingspan make them  incredibly skilled soaring birds  they breed and forage in open fields and  wetlands and can often be seen visiting  farmers fields on the hunt for leftover  seeds  while their population has rebounded in  the last few decades loss of habitat and  climate change are still looming threats  this is the sandhill crane  you